it's a day that ends in why and so the
libs are attempting to promote yet
another weird sex thing having already
succeeded at convincing people of a
dubious new definition of marriage and
the possibility that a man can become a
woman and the health benefits of onism
the libs are now focusing their
rhetorical skill on persuading us all of
the moral good of
orgies the latest issue of New York
Magazine takes up the challenge as the
magazine explains quote the new issue
explores the world of ethical non-
monogamy brief
digression if you have to describe
something specifically as ethical it
probably is not ethical non- monogamy is
a contradiction in terms it is like a
vegan lion or elderly babies if the
adjectives and the nouns contradict one
another then you have a classic leftist
expression this is a rhetorical trick
the libs use all the time undocumented
American is a classic example of that
there is no such thing as an
undocumented American because the reason
that said undocumented American doesn't
have documents is because he's not an
American so the phrase is contradictory
New York Magazine goes on quote the
package includes a feature by Allison
Davis on one specific polycule and
offers poly curious readers an in-depth
guide to opening up their relationships
an in-depth guide the libs are not just
detailing the degenerate behavior of
weirdos they are actively trying to get
you to try it too but they know it's
degenerate no matter how many times they
Jam that word ethical in there they know
that this behavior is repulsive and
disordered and the proof of that is that
the cover image on the magazine is a
bunch of
kittens cute little kittens
an accurate portrayal of polyamory would
depict sad girls with daddy issues and
brain fried sers so why kittens it's the
same trick that they pulled when they
appropriated the rainbow the libs always
appropriate cherished symbols and then
they use them to their own disordered
ends because the reality that they're
pedaling turns people off so they lure
you in with lies and by the time you
become aware of the nasty reality they
have already moved on to their next
disorder ordered lust right now go to
genucell.com
letter y letter T here is a great New
Year's resolution you can actually keep
whether you have 3 minutes in the
morning or 30 minutes keep your face
wrinkle-free with genucel introducing
gen 90 the new instant wrinkle treatment
from jusl gen 90 instantly reduces the
appearance of wrinkles anywhere you use
it from around your eyes forehead crows
feet or laugh lines it starts working in
seconds genus cell says their gen 90 is
two generations better than any
immediate effects product in the years
ahead of the skincare market and I
believe them these guys are fanatical
about using the absolute best
ingredients in the business they bring
them to you at an insanely low price the
technology is luxurious nourishing it's
silk smooth the results are game
changers for you or your money back what
are you waiting for make your fine lines
and wrinkles disappear with jus cell
right now our listeners will get not
only over 70 70% off genell's most
popular package but also free shipping
head on over to jus cell.com n lettery
letter T and secure your gen 90 product
before they sell out that is
genucell.com
lettert today Mass migration continues
to be a major issue this has been a
major issue now for almost a decade in
its recent form and it's cropped up over
the years but especially in recent years
in America obviously it a big part of
the Trump winning 16 in the UK in Italy
in Hungary in Poland in all over Europe
all over the west mass migration is a
big problem the Dems still don't get
that
message I think Joe mansion and John
fedman are the two Democrats in the
entire country who realize that just
opening up the borders and flooding the
country with foreigners is not maybe
necessarily the most prudent idea the
rest the rest of the Dems are insisting
that open borders and mass migration is
not only a good thing but it is
profoundly essentially American here we
have
Democrat Congressman Max
Frost to my colleagues on the other side
of the aisle let's be honest with
immigrants who deserve better than what
you're offering them don't welcome
immigrants if you plan to reject them if
you keep pushing your bigoted hr2 bill
then also pass this bill I've taken the
liberty of drafting it for you it
removes the Statue of Liberty our
largest symbol that tells people to come
here this is who you are removing the
fabric of America so I want to know
which Republican who supports and voted
for hr2 will introduce this bill the
Statue of Liberty doesn't actually tell
foreigners to come here certainly
doesn't tell them to come here in in
violation of our laws certainly doesn't
tell them to come here illegally and and
in infinite numbers but it doesn't tell
them to come here at all the Statue of
Liberty is a beacon of light to the rest
of the
world it is to
illuminate and provide a model for the
rest of the world the Statue of Liberty
is not a statue of Atilla the Hun
tearing down our borders it's not a
statue of genas Khan conquering our
country it's a Statue of Liberty I'm not
even all that hot on the Statue of
Liberty I mean don't forget it was given
to us by the French the French and not
even the good old aristocratic Catholic
who are totally nuts Who sacked churches
and replaced the traditional religion
with with temples of reason and chopped
up all the neighborhoods and made them
all really dumb and gave us the metric
metric system and just all G was a gift
from them so I you know I like it I'm a
New Yorker I like the Statue of Liberty
but it does not mean what he says it
means the reason this guy thinks that
the Statue of Liberty tells foreigners
to flood into our country in violate of
our laws is because there's a poem on
the Statue of Liberty called what's it
called the Great Colossus I think it is
it's by Emma
Lazarus it was it was a poem added on
put there at Ellis Island in
18 89 or something was latter part of
the 19th century this woman Emma Lazarus
was a socialist she was te actually
specifically a georgist which is a
forgotten political economic program but
it's just a version of socialism and
yeah yeah I'm sure that some
weirdo socialists in the 19th century
wanted to make a French statue even more
radical but that is not in the American
tradition oh and by the way guess what
happened about 30 to 40 years after we
got the Statue of Liberty and even we
put the poem there we severely curtailed
migration for half a century that's what
we did we instituted the Immigration Act
of 1924 and we severely curtailed the
number of immigrants who could come into
the country we tied it to to National
and ethnic quotas and we totally
excluded Asians okay so it's pretty
restrictive I'm not I'm not suggesting
that any Republican is calling for a
return to that but don't tell me that it
totally undermines American history we
we have had from the very beginning of
our country very very severe
restrictions on immigration for much if
not most of our
history okay it's not the country is not
what these people say it is for goodness
sakes man what a great clip that was now
hold up ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael NS YouTube channel we'll see you
next time